the yankees are looking for the sweep
of the boston red sox and their 11th
straight win the magic number is one
to clinch a postseason berth it gets a
little more complicated clinching a
fourth spot
and clinching the number two seed uh in
the al east but we'll get to that tanner
houck
yeah a little tougher test today against
the yankees for tanner but last time out
we saw that sweeping breaking ball one
of his best bits
tough against right-handers two
fastballs and a change-up split that's
a work in progress
that's a shot out to right plyo right
there who's hit right at him
for a quick out and here he is davey
garcia going to make his
fifth big league start here at fenway
park
he's talked a lot about pedro martinez
and being his idol and yeah that's the
mound pedro did his work on
for the majority of his career so you
know this kid is fired up
three of those four starts so far have
been quality starts the 1-0
rounded up the middle right there is
wade
away raffy devers snapped an 18
game on base streak last night with the
offer
he's going to launch that one toward
left center field and that's going to
catch some green
back down for gardner he's into second
base with a double so he said enough of
that
not being on base and hits one off the
wall for two bases
paul just jumps off his back that time
he got a fastball again
this time contact and good contact to
the opposite field that ball is right
down the middle
so chavis to step in 207 three home runs
for the bundled up left fielder
high fly ball that one deep way back
there it goes and she
is gone disappearing from sight
chavis with a two-run shot to put the
socks in front
davis says i got your curveball right
here and he just
loses it no